what regions do you think are going to
start taking a hit
well our company has been doing better
while everybody else has been laying off
we've been very blessed in that sense
and that's because the majority of our
clients are people looking to build
wealthy real estate not just find a
house so if you want to buy a house that
rate going up makes it much less
affordable yes but if you want to invest
in real estate the rate is just a number
on a page and if the numbers work it
doesn't matter if your rate's twenty
percent or two percent numbers how much
is the rent that's coming in what are
your other expenses is this a short-term
rental that brings in more money or is
this a traditional rental that will
bring in less so because a majority of
our clients are coming from a wealth
building perspective we haven't slowed
down what rates do is affect demand see
this is the problem is people say rates
are going up prices should go down just
how it has to work that way
affordability is going down no demand is
going down less people want to buy
that's exactly right now if you were at
equilibrium there was a house for every
buyer and rates went up making demand go
down prices would have to go this is
when I hear Pat talk about this or other
people talk about they're right they're
just a little there's more Nuance to it
if you're in an area that already did
not have enough Supply it was like not
enough houses or 20 people for every one
home and demand goes down you're still
not going to see prices go down you can
keep raising rates more and more and
more and more the prices aren't
adjusting so they hit that equilibrium
and there's a lot of markets in the
country where there is not enough supply
for the people that want it and
businesses keep moving in their
businesses are thriving Miami is one of
those areas you might not see the
ridiculous the compser 700 we're going
to list the 800 and see what happens but
that doesn't mean you have a crash it
never should have been at 800. you're
going to see people pricing their homes
where they probably should have been
pricing them in the beginning other
markets where there's too much supply
for the demand they will be hit very
hard by this interest rate increases a
lot of places in the midwest Kansas
Kentucky like you're going to see like
those are not going to do super well and
you said that's because there there's
more too much Supply than demand to move
to
Bumble fall Kansas that's exactly right
Idaho not enough Supply All The
Californians are trying to move into
Idaho oh
yeah he's trying to move to these types
of places yeah so they're not going to
see the prices they're not going to go
down wealthy people can still afford
that they're not looking at it isn't
more expensive than it used to be
they're looking at it is this a better
investment than this yeah and if they're
willing to put in the work like managing
a short-term rental that's the stuff
that I've been buying at Fort Lauderdale
Pompano Beach Hollywood I'm gonna keep
buying out here they're more work to run
those it's a business you're buying it's
a small little business but the return
on that money is going to be so much
more than anything else I can put it in
rates can keep going up I'm gonna keep
buying it gotcha so is there um not
because it sounds like obviously you're
based in Cali you have properties out
here do you have properties all across
the country yeah okay you're you're
you're you're you're looking the
national perspective right it's not like
you're like a South Florida Specialist
or a California specialist per se you're
an American Real Estate specialist
That's it fair to say uh what city or
cities have the best bang for your buck
these days in your opinion Tennessee is
doing really well that's because you're
getting so many Californians that move
there there's no state income tax you're
talking to Nashville you're talking to
Memphis whatever uh no more than
Nashville side okay I think
um South Florida everywhere you're
getting a lot of bang for your buck
right now
Broken Bow Oklahoma had a really big run
because they put a casino out there and
it's like a vacation area that people
would go vacation at it got way too hot
so that's coming down it's tough to
answer that question because we're
having such a reset like so many of the
buyers have pulled out of the buyer pool
they're like I don't know what to expect
with this rates just keep going up I
hear of a talk of a crash are we going
to war with Russia no one knows a lot of
the buyers have come out of there when
you send the buyers just mean General
people generally can they get into the
market no one likes when there's change
that happens rapidly yeah they don't
make big decisions the world economic
stuff has changed and rates are going up
by 75 basis points just like every
couple weeks yeah so if you like that
clip click right here to watch another
or if you want to watch the entire
saucecast click right here
foreign
[Music]